earlier today talking about his
quarterback patrick mahomes who if
you've been asleep for the last 24 hours
suffered a concussion yesterday in the
second half of the win over the browns
here's reid
i really don't
have any injuries to
talk about
um other than
uh patrick's and eason protocol there so
um
and we'll just follow that and see how
he how he does here
the next couple days
i i don't have any injuries to talk
about except the most important guy on
the team
other than that we're fine no problem
other than the fact that we may not have
patreon homes i don't want to be
flipping about it but we don't know that
he's going to be cleared to play and you
know i asked the league if they have any
numbers that they keep because my
recollection is sharing tell me if i'm
wrong um
when they first became sensitive to the
concussion problem 2009 october 28th
demora smith and roger goodell got
called up to capitol hill they had a big
hearing and and that was the the lesson
and the message take it seriously
and get guys off the field if they have
a concussion and don't let them back on
until they've been properly cleared by
an independent neurologist fine
the first few years if you had a
concussion
one sunday you didn't play the next
sunday
now
when a guy has a concussion it seems
like more often than not he does play
the nfl said the median number of missed
days
by a quarterback due to a concussion
from 2015 through 2019 is seven
29 quarterbacks in the sample size and
keep in mind as the doctors will say if
you've seen one concussion you've seen
one concussion everyone is different and
the thing that was different about my
home yesterday there wasn't any obvious
traumatic blow to the head
there was kind of a dragging down and it
was his neck but he was clearly woozy
clearly affected and and it's it's all
down to shireen how quickly his brain
recovers from the trauma could be sunday
could not be sunday we may not see him
again until the super bowl assuming that
the chiefs somehow win with chad honey
and andy reid had an unfortunate phrase
that he used he said it was a no-brainer
and i'm sure he didn't mean it this way
obviously but it's it is a no-brainer
from a coach's standpoint because the
coach has nothing to do with whether he
can play or not play he just has to get
his team prepared and prepared if he
plays prepared if he doesn't play and
that's what sean mcdermott said too
we'll prepare for two quarterbacks and
that's what you have to do at this point
basically you're preparing for a system
but i'm sure they'll have to put two
game plans in mike because they're not
going to know it's out of their hands an
independent neurologist has to clear
patrick mahomes from this it's not going
to be
simply the chief saying
he's good to go and patrick mahomes
saying i can play it's not going to be
that simple and best case scenario
probably for the chiefs is he's not
going to practice much if at all this
week mike if but if they can just get
him back on the field they'll be happy
with that
two levels of clearance by the
independent neurologist one to practice
two to play and the mere fact that the
nfl incorporated the independent
neurologist and i know it's got a more
fancy official name but basically it's
somebody who's not on the team payroll
pre-2009 and we've gotten so used to
this now we forget what the world was
like before before 2009
the doctor who was paid by the team
was signing off on whether or not the
quarterback or any other player could
play with a concussion and obviously if
that doctor wanted to continue to be
employed by the team to provide services
to the players it wasn't going to
keep players away from the team and that
that has been removed and it seems to
have been once they apply shireen the
concussion label it seems that that is
followed and that is respected and that
is honored the challenge is getting to
the application the concussion label and
i was watching very carefully yesterday
would they take patrick mahomes to the
locker room the locker room is the best
place to do the full-blown concussion
evaluation and he was so obviously
impaired
that that was
an easy decision to make we've seen guys
who weren't clearly
woozy and guys who worked their way back
onto the field like russell wilson a few
years ago so you know we always worry
about an issue like that in the
postseason and you don't want to have a
guy unnecessarily be put in the locker
room for 15 minutes and it turns out he
didn't have a concussion in this case
the protocol worked mahomes was
scratched and now now we see if the
protocol on the back end works and uh if
it works in favor of the chiefs or in
favor of the bills because there is a
clear strategic opponent here and he's
got a bad toe we forgot about the bad
toe
the the the big toe he clearly had his
foot bent in
because he was trying to put weight on
the outside of the foot away from the
big toe that's an issue as well and you
know i said earlier today on pft live it
could have been a blessing in disguise
that he suffered the concussion in a
weird sort of way because it got him off
the foot and it and it avoided any
further damage to the foot so maybe if
he'd played the whole game the toe would
have been too much of a problem
for him to play this sunday but we'll
see how that all plays out we have the
toe we have the concussion and we may or
may not have patrick mahomes come sunday
yeah and andy reed blew off the toe
issue but he was limping around mike and
he was not the same guy and you know i
was surprised that he ran on that
particular play simply because the toe
was messed up and it didn't look like a
hard hit and i know what we just put up
what mama mahomes said randy mahomes
patrick mahomes mom said on on twitter
and criticized mack wilson for the hit
but you know the hit didn't look that
bad it didn't look like he took the
direct hit to the head and i really
thought that it was going to be a neck
injury and then you got up like you said
you saw he was was woozy you saw he was
out of it you saw he probably had a
concussion at that point it didn't even
take a neurologist at that point to say
he's got to get back to the locker room
to be tested out for this thing because
he doesn't know where he is so hopefully
he's okay and can get back on the field
and and can maybe can even practice some
this week we'll just see how that plays
out but in a weird sort of way mike this
works in the chief's advantage a little
bit because the bills do have to prepare
for both quarterbacks they do have to
spend that time on chad henny that they
otherwise wouldn't have done
and chad henny gave them something to
think about it ended up being a good
thing that patrick holmes didn't play
week 17 chad henny able to knock off
some rust and be ready to go two weeks
later when it was time for him to come
in with very short notice back to the
randy mahomes thing we're going to talk
later about the actual hit and the
penalty and whether he should have been
running etc but the the as to
whether it was an illegal hit there was
a lowering of the helmet and initiation
of contact and it doesn't have to be
helmet to helmet but that penalty gets
called so haphazardly we saw a clear
violation when daniel sorensen hit
rashard higgins and caused the fumble
that went out of the end zone and that
was the focal point of the controversy
there still was an uncalled foul for
lowering of the helmet initiating
contact we saw it in the saints bucks
game it was a grazing of the helmet
by the lowering of the helmet it wasn't
a direct blow and they called it then so
this is something that was written so
broadly there are so many hits that fall
within the boundaries of a violation and
sometimes they get called and sometimes
they don't the key will be whether or
not mac wilson gets fined shireen this
weekend that would be the concession by
the league office that maybe it should
have been flagged for lowering the
helmet making contact with the opponent
and in this case contributing to the
concussion that patrick mahomes suffered
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports